et c'est 1 2 1 2 on enregistre
on est ici pour mener une enquête sur le
patient qui a tué trois adolescents le
soir d'halloween 1978 il s'est fait
tirer dessus par son propre petit 4 il a
été arrêté cette nuit là et il a passé
ces quarante dernières années en
captivité bonjour michael j'ai quelque
chose que vous aimeriez peut-être revoir
oh
dans ma famille tout le monde pète un
câble à cette période de l'année
quand même ta grand mère c'est laurie
strode elle a failli se faire tuer
c'était pas son frère qui avait
assassiné des baby-sitters non c'était
pas son frère
les gens sont fait des films vous savez
que je prie tous les soirs pour qu'ils
s'évadent pourquoi vous faites une chose
pareille pour lui faire la peau
[Musique]
le bus a eu un accident
maman quel bus a eu un accident michael
s'était évadé
[Musique]
c'est déjà occupé désolé il ya quelqu'un
ils attendaient cette nuit m'attend des
mois
je l'attendais moi aussi
[Musique]
vous croyez pas aux croque mitaine non
il est là michael
[Musique]
devriez tu peux fermer la porte du
placard
[Musique]